marcó la salida del republicano donald
trump del poder y conmocionó a los
estadounidenses cuando el 6 de enero una
turba de ciudadanos simpatizantes del
republicano entro al capitolio en lo que
se conoce como el asalto ahora un año y
seis meses después un comité de
investigación persigue responsabilidades
ianywhere six el 6 de enero fue la
culminación de un intento de golpe de
estado un intento descarado como dijo un
alborotador poco después del 6 de enero
de derrocar al gobierno la violencia no
fue un accidente
y una acusación directa contra el
expresidente donald trump señalado por
dirigir el asalto con testimonios de su
propio círculo cercano asegurando que le
rogaron no incitar a sus seguidores a
entrar en el capitolio tras publicar en
mensajes incendiarios en redes sociales
jugé events escucharán pruebas de que el
presidente de trump se negó durante
horas a hacer lo que sus empleados su
familia y muchos de sus asesores le
rogaron que hiciera instruir
inmediatamente a sus partidarios para
que se retiraran evacuar en el capitolio
pero entre los testigos su antiguo
asesor y portavoz
jason miller y el ex fiscal general
william p bar y hasta su propia hija
ivanka trump
le dije repetidamente al presidente en
términos inequívocos que no veía pruebas
de fraude no hay ninguna base para las
acusaciones pero se hicieron de una
manera tan sensacionalista que
obviamente estaban incluyendo a un
montón de gente
afectó mi perspectiva respeto al fiscal
general bar así que acepte lo que decía
que el guaje se usan junto a imágenes
inéditas de la violencia de aquel día el
comité presentó pruebas de que grupos
ultranacionalistas como los sprout voice
estuvieron planeando desde noviembre
cómo hacer que trump permaneciera en el
gobierno un tema que se seguirá
indagando en las audiencias de la
próxima semana